[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
édition spéciale sur tv fil 78 au cours
de la prochaine demi heure nous allons
revenir sur ce scrutin présidentiel
quels résultats quels enseignements et
quelles conséquences dans les yvelines
voici les titres emmanuel macron est en
tête dans les yvelines le candidat en
marche réalise un meilleur score qu'au
niveau national nous étions aux côtés
des militants à l'annoncé des résultats
françois fillon résiste dans le
département il termine à la seconde
place mais en fonction des communes son
score varie fortement quant à benoît
hamon il ne parvient pas l'emporter sur
ses terres et puis le front national
progresse peu par rapport à 2012 dans
les yvelines toujours la france
insoumise termine même devant sur la
troisième marche du podium les détails à
suivre pour nous accompagner au cours de
cette édition spéciale stéphane minson
bonsoir en soit vous êtes le doyen
honoraire de la faculté de droit et de
sciences politiques à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines on
va analyser ces différents résultats et
les résultats elle les voici justement
concernant l les yvelines tout d'abord
emmanuel macron est donc en tête à 28,86
% des suffrages exprimés devant françois
fillon pour les républicains à 27,25 %
suivent ensuite jean luc mélenchon
marine le pen et benoît hamon un
résultat qui contraste légèrement avec
le résultat à nationale puisque si
emmanuel macron et bien en tête son
score est inférieur et marine le pen
vous le savez est qualifié elle est
deuxième avec 21,43 % des voix c'est un
scrutin historique
il faut en retenir quoi dans les grandes
lignes qu'est ce qui vous a marqué le
plus ya de nombreux enseignements mais
l'enseignement essentiel pour vous dans
les grandes lignes je dirais ya trois
peut-être 3 3 très bref d'enseignement
le premier c'est que aucun des deux
grands partis classiques ne parvient à
se qualifier pour le pour le second tour
et c'est en soit tout à fait
révolutionnaire la droite parlementaire
se qualifier nécessairement à chaque
second tour depuis 1965 c'est à dire
depuis la première élection
présidentielle
quant à la gauche socialiste
et non socialiste elle n'est pas
présente le deuxième enseignement c'est
que on a quand même marine le pen
au-delà de 21 22% et cette fois si
j'allais dire ce n'est pas un accident
de l'histoire pas comme en 2002 quand la
7 est annoncé depuis longtemps
jean-marie le pen s'était retrouvé suite
à la défaite de jospin et on a vraiment
un front national qui est de mon point
de vue au centre du jeu politique
aujourd'hui
et puis le troisième enseignement c'est
l'arrivée d'un candidat qui jusqu'à il
ya deux ans à peu près et est inconnue
jacques attali avait dans une lune de
ses prédictions analysé que le président
français de 2010 est serait un inconnu
c'était il ya à peu près cinq ans et je
trouve que c'est assez étonnant de voir
que tout cela est aujourd'hui vérifie
alors s'il fallait aller chercher les
résultats de cette élection dans les
prédictions de jacques attali peut-être
sa tournée par conrad sorte élections je
devrais dire analyse après dix
prédictions ou si c'était vrai ce que
des prédictions mais on va revenir donc
sur ces différents événements au cours
de cette demi heure avec notamment
nicolas landry et nicolas kerry le vide
pour la rédaction bonsoir à tous les
deux auparavant quelques réactions dans
les rues de saint quentin en yvelines
enregistré aujourd'hui un micro-trottoir
préparer à part patrick jacques de
dixmude mois et coûté au moins ça prouve
qu'il ya du changement que l'ère du
changement en france apparemment
les gens ont rejeté un petit peu les
partis politiques traditionnels et après
tout on va voir moi je pense que c'est
plutôt favorable à l'économie et au bien
de la france de toute façon pour rien
rien non mais vraiment rien perplexe
parce que voilà les candidats qui
restent
ne me conviennent pas donc je crois que
pour la deuxième fois de ma vie je vais
voter blanc il est conforme aux
prévisions en fait j'ai trouvé ça
surprenant
disons le mot surprenant et
parce que moi j'ai très peur du front du
front national c'est une totale surprise
mais vu le climat des terres qu'ils
avaient
c'est pas c'est pas étonnant et moi
personnellement je suis satisfait des
résultats
l'édition spéciale sur tv filet nous
revenons notamment sur l'une des grandes
questions irc à cette question de
l'abstention finalement allé plus
importante sur le plan national en 2017
quand 2012 pour ce premier tour elle
s'établit à 21 77 %
qu'en est-il dans les yvelines alors sur
le département situation inverse au plan
national l'abstention baisse par rapport
à il ya cinq ans 21,18 % en 2012 contre
18,66 % ce dimanche c'est donc une
baisse assez significatives tout de même
précisons que plus de sept cent soixante
dix mille personnes au total se sont
déplacés aux urnes pour ce premier tour
de la présidentielle dans les yvelines
le département des yvelines qui fait
figure de bon élève en ile de france
puisque en région parisienne
l'abstention dépasse légèrement les 20 %
pour s'établir à 20,11 % les yvelinois
étaient donc nombreux à se mobiliser
pour ce 23 avril écouter ces quelques
réactions que nous avions recueilli
dimanche après midi dans le parc des
sources de la bièvre à guyancourt
oui j'ai été votée parce que c'est notre
devoir de citoyen et que on a l'occasion
de donner notre voix à 18 et 19 ans je
voudrais qu'on me le fais je pense que
c'est important parce qu'on nous donne
l'occasion de voter donc même si c'est
pas c'est pas très claires et au final
on va choisir plutôt le moins pire c'est
un droit qu'on a et ce droit là on peut
pas nous l'enlever donc il faut aller
voter parce que c'est important enfin on
est la jeunesse et je pense que c'est
important de faire peser sont ouvertes
surtout dans le cadre d'élections à la
présidentielle franchement fiche mais
c'est pas un peu pour s'arrêter sinon
moi je voterai pas franchement puisque
je trouve que c'est nul on fait voter
sarin et puis je parle de rester en
france plus tard pour ma part j'ai voté
parce que je trouve ça important que
chacun puisse exprimer son
on ses opinions et voilà je pense
qu'elle forcément un candidat qui
correspond
j'estime que c'est un droit qu'on a et
c'est important de le respecter certains
ne l'ont pas donc il faut agir en tant
que citoyen et surtout c'est une
élection plus qu'importante dans
l'histoire de notre pays
l'abstention au niveau national
l'abstention dans les yvelines qu'en
est-il à saint quentin en yvelines dans
l'agglomération alors à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines wilfried il ya
deux communes qui ont moins voté que les
autres et c'est malheureusement une
habitude pour elle désormais ce sont
deux villes ancré à gauche la verrière
plus de 31 % d'abstention pour ce
premier tour et rappelé le fief
électoral de benoît hamon 29,1 % de non
votants al'inverse parmi elles les bons
élèves de l'agglomération retrouve
montigny-le-bretonneux magny les hameaux
et mention spéciale pour voisins le
bretonneux seulement 15 % d'abstention
c'est quatre points de moins qu'en 2012
pour voisins le bretonneux
merci nicolas stéphane mensonge est ce
que l'on peut en tirer des enseignements
dans le cadre du second tour est ce que
l'abstention va rester faible pour le
second tour le plus inquiétante je lis
fin l'histoire l'histoire montre que
lorsqu'un premier tour et couronnée
d'une participation assez forte comme
c'est souvent le cas et comme ça a été
le cas en dépit de ce qu'on avait pu
envisager et bien montre que le second
tour suisse cette même dynamique en
règle générale à quelques quelques
décilitres avait une crainte pour le
premier tour sur la sur la participation
sur un taux élevé d'abstention
finalement les français ont décidé de se
mobiliser d'aller aux urnes qu'est-ce
qui a pu comme ça les décider parce
qu'il avait grossi beaucoup d'indécis
jusqu alors ce qui ce qui a pu les
décider c'est que je pense que les
français ont toujours le goût de la
politique et surtout ce qui est
important la campagne était longue un
plus à la campagne a été très longue
mais je les meetings était relativement
remplis enfin tout dépend pour qui bat
pour la plupart des candidats je pense
que ce qu'on peut en conclure ce qu'il y
avait quand même un enjeu
il y avait un enjeu peut-être comme il
n'a jamais eu jusqu'à présent avec
quatre candidats qui se tenait par la
barbichette les uns par rapport aux
autres il y avait un véritable ange et
avec une cristallisation comme on dit
qui est intervenu de manière très
tardive pas avant les 3 semaines à
quinze jours qui ont précédé le scrutin
emmanuel macron l'a donc emporté à
l'issue de ce premier tour il est en
tête au niveau national il s'impose
aussi dans notre département et nous
étions avec ses militants yvelinois
c'était à versailles hier soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à 39 ans sans avoir exercé de mandat et
un an après la création de son mouvement
en marche
emmanuel macron accède donc au second
tour de l'élection présidentielle
c'est les yeux rougis que le responsable
du mouvement dans les yvelines a pris
connaissance des résultats à 20 heures
moi je n'ai jamais fait de politique ma
vie ça n'a jamais été mon ambition
j'étais venu juste pour faire un bout de
parcours sur un projet citoyen la grande
marche et de la voilà il a poussé il
nous a donné confiance à nous donc
services it et c'est vraiment un plaisir
d'être là bas pourtant pour ce moment là
vainqueur de ce premier tour au niveau
national vainqueur également dans les
yvelines emmanuel macron il devance
françois fillon d'un peu plus d'un point
emmanuel macron a su réconcilier
certains de droite certains de gauche il
a dit qu'il y avait des bonnes idées par
sont tous et moi ça me plaît beaucoup
comme état d'esprit moi j'attends déjà
sans l'attendre
depuis 50 ans depuis servan-schreiber et
le manifeste du parti radical
alors c'est incroyable aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est d'ores et déjà fait le
résultat du second
non bien sûr que non c'est jamais fait
les fachos ils ont donc toujours ils ont
ils le restent toujours d une carte dans
la manche on sait pas ce qu'ils peuvent
sortir jusqu'au dernier moment donc on
ira se battre pour que la victoire soit
encore plus belle dans certaines
communes du département le score du
leader dans marche dépassent les 30 %
c'est le cas à maurepas montigny le
bretonneux ou voisins le bretonneux
de quoi donner des sueurs froides aux
futurs adversaires du mouvement lors des
législatives et ravir les alliés
centristes du modem
alors on nous reproche certains certains
certaines valiance mais il faut qu'il
faut pas que les gens oublient une chose
c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'on a fait des
annonces on les a faites autour d'un
projet écrit et qui nous paraissait
aller dans le sens de l'intérêt général
on n'a jamais fait d'alliance pour
obtenir des postes
on a d'abord travaillé sur les projets
et ensuite on a vu comment on pouvait
faire ferrer aider les gens avec qui on
avait les violences restent pour le
moment à l'emporter au second tour de la
présidentielle dans les yvelines les
responsables de gauche comme de droite
appellent majoritairement à le soutenir
à l'exception très nette de christine
boutin conseillère départementale qui
n'exclut pas un vote front national
autre qualifié pour le second tour le
front national marine le pen fait même
mieux que son père 15 ans après en terme
d'électeurs plus de 7 millions de voix
contre 4 millions à l'époque pour jean
marie le pen néanmoins cela ne devrait
pas être suffisant pour l'emporter dans
quinze jours si l'on en croit les
différents sondages
quant au résultat national il ne devrait
pas être suffisant non plus pour créer
une dynamique dans le département en vue
des élections de législatives dans le f
dans le département des yvelines le fn
termine termine avec un peu plus de 13%
des suffrages haussmann vendeurs de leur
candidate marine le pen est au deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle
pourtant ses partisans réunis dans un
bar à versailles sont déçus dans les
yvelines la présidente du front national
récolte 12 9% des voix contre 12,4 en
2012 une petite déception parce que je
pense qu'on aurait pu faire plus
maintenant je suis très satisfait qu'on
soit un second tour surtout face à un
candidat qui prône le mondialisme
sauvage et nous on protège la france la
patrie
maintenant je sais pas si si ça change
vraiment le fait qu'elle est avec plus
ou moins de pourcentage parce que je
pense que c'est maintenant ce que les
vrais débats vont avoir lieu parce qu'il
ya eu beaucoup de débats qui ont été
escamotées marine le pen récolte 9,8
pour cent des voix à versailles 9 3% à
montigny le bretonneux à montville
seules communes d'île de france dirigé
par le fn la candidate obtient 22,3 pour
cent elle est devancée par jean luc
mélenchon avec 28,6 pour cent de son
côté le secrétaire départemental du
front national françois simeoni
relativise c'est une grande satisfaction
on va pouvoir montrer aux français
très exposée pendant les 15 jours qui
restent notre programme l'expliqué est
donné ce choix formidable de sociétés
dont une quinzaine de jours et le mot
d'ordre est simple pour ces 15 derniers
jours de campagne c'est de mettre à mal
le programme d' emmanuel macron celle
que je vous propose c'est la grande
alternance l'alternance fondamentale qui
mettra en place une autre politique
d'autres visages au pouvoir et le
renouvellement auquel vous aspirez ce
n'est évidemment pas avec l'héritier de
françois hollande et de tous les échecs
de ce quinquennat catastrophique que
cette alternance tant attendu viendra le
3 mai un débat aura lieu sur france 2 et
tf1 entre marine le pen et emmanuel
macron le front national a maintenant 15
jours pour séduire les français
stéphane mans sont évoquées à tout à
l'heure l'un des enseignements ses sept
victoires dans l'inconnu finalement sur
ce premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle pour cette année puis
l'autre enseignement c'est donc le front
national qui termine finalement la
deuxième place longtemps annoncée en
tête dans les différents sondages et se
placent plafond de verre qui peut être
se fissure mais qui n'est toujours pas
casser pour le front national ce plafond
de verre qui n'est pas cassée mais mais
retenons quand même qu'en dépit des
prévisions qui date d'il ya 3 mois 4
mois on donnait un front national pas
loin de 30 parfois voire parfois au delà
de 30
le score en lui même n'est pas un
mauvais score mais ça n'est pas celui
très probablement qui était attendu par
les par les membres du fn eux mêmes et
je alors je suis pas le seul à le
signaler mais je trouve que la campagne
de marine le pen a été mauvaise c'est
une campagne qui a tourné en boucle avec
les mêmes thématiques qui reviennent
sans arrêt le même disque que vous
remettez 7 ans ou cinq ans plus tard
avec exactement la même musique s'est
passé à faire aussi par les affaires des
attachés parlementaires
ben écoute et on va attaquer françois
fillon sur ce terrain là oui enfin là
pas trop osé le faire mais je trouve
qu'elle a quand même donné le change
c'est à dire que il doit être un peu
embêté et j'ose l'espérer mais elle a
quand même pas se montrer
tendant bêtement que cela tant
d'embarras que cela au total on peut
quand même dire que 7 million et demi
d'électeurs pour une élection
présidentielle envers une candidate du
front national c'est en soit absolument
énorme mais il restera à voir maintenant
le report des voix pour le second tour
que vont faire les électeurs de françois
fillon voire de jean-luc mélenchon et
puis on l'évoquera aussi tout à l'heure
avec les plus petits candidats avec vous
à nicolas la question de nicolas dupont
aignan alors le département des yvelines
vous le savez jusqu'à présent était
plutôt ancré à droite françois fillon
est arrivé en deuxième position 13 mille
voix le sépare des manuels macron les
affaires semblent avoir un peu pesé dans
le choix des électeurs
mais ce soutien aux représentants à d un
républicain du département ne suffit
donc pas le qualifier au second tour et
coûté suzanne blanc et lui à montigny le
bretonneux c'est l'une des responsables
de campagne dans les yvelines elle était
très laid suis retrouvée qu'est ce que
je peux vous dire un sentiment de
tristesse forcément quand on s'est battu
pendant tant de mois voire tant d'années
bien évidemment on ne peut être que
triste déçu
voilà mais c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
c'est c'est la loi de c'est la loi du
suffrage universel
les français se sont prononcés derrière
cette deuxième place dans le département
pour françois fillon il ya de grandes
différences au niveau et des différentes
communes ainsi l encours françois fillon
totalise 18 77% des voix derrière
emmanuel macron et jean luc mélenchon
écouter le maire de la commune
il faut que monsieur mac on sorte de
cette image de communication et qui nous
disent vraiment avec qui il veut
gouverner quelles sont ses engagements
économiques quelle majorité quelle
premier ministre et et si on tombe
d'accord sur un minimum de règles qui
remet notre pays qui relancent
l'économie l'investissement productif
les emplois le niveau de vie la
protection des retraites et du modèle
social français
oui on sera attentif et on sera positif
ça va de soi si monsieur macron partage
ce type de projet et souhaitent une
majorité avec des gens sérieux
voilà moi je serais je serai de bonne
volonté autres comme une montigny le
bretonneux françois fillon et est
deuxième avec presque 20 % des suffrages
emmanuel macron lui dépasse les 35 % là
aussi réaction du maire par ailleurs
président de saint quentin en yvelines
michel dauchy et résiste bien mais vous
savez de là il n'y a pas de résister aux
pas résisté soit des présents au second
tour soit on ne l'est pas je regrette
qu'ils doivent à présent au second tour
parce qu'effectivement les affaires sont
venus plomber un petit peu tout et cette
campagne et c'est vrai que bon il ne
faisait pas parti lui de l'élite de la
presse donc la pâte forcément été bien
encadrés et soutenus par il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de vraie campagne
on notera en revanche qu'à rambouillet
françois fillon est en tête avec plus de
28% en tête également à versailles avec
42 99% des suffrages les ténors
politiques du département ont rapidement
appelé à voter emmanuel macron second
tour de gérard larcher président du
sénat à valérie pécresse présidente de
la région ou encore par un pierre bédier
le président du département des yvelines
aujourd'hui les républicains doivent se
réorganiser et plutôt vite stéphane
mention puisqu'il ya ce troisième tour
les élections législatives est ce que
c'est possible que pour une formation
politique de se réorganiser même si
c'est inédit que ni ps ni public c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué parce que au
regard notamment les leurs aujourd'hui
banon et puis on regarde l'inversion du
calendrier entre élections
présidentielle et législatives on sait
que ce sont désormais les
présidentielles qui font oeuvre de
dynamique pour les législatives
et c'est ce qui ad'ailleurs été voulue
au regard de la révision
constitutionnelle donc très compliqué
pour les républicains mais encore plus
compliqué pour les socialistes tout ce
qui nous reste
on va évoquer le cadet des socialistes
juste concernant les républicains un
dernier mot sur la ligne de conduite des
différents ténors justement parce que
jean frédéric poisson l'ancien candidat
à la primaire député des yvelines
président du parti chrétien démocrate
lui n'entend pas glissé un bulletin
macron dans l'urne à écouter la jeune
marine le pen n'est pas bon pour le pays
et que c'est mon sentiment c'est bien
mais maintenant n'est pas meilleure pour
qu' il faut il faut y ont de toute façon
grâce à une
une forte poussée dans des élections
législatives que nous soyons en
situation de faire valoir notre projet
politique et républicains et leurs
alliés et une très grande timidité pour
ne pas dire une suite de renoncement qui
nous vaut un retrait père de la part des
français ça veut dire que si nous
faisons l'analyse et il faudra faire à
froid de ce qui s'est passé hier nous
devons en tirer toutes les conséquences
en matière de fidélité à notre propre
faute de valeur parce que c'est ça que
les français attendent de nous on va
regarder maintenant un peu plus en
détail le résultat de benoît hamon dans
les yvelines résultats du parti
socialiste le coût est encore plus rude
le ps poursuit cette chute infernale
entamé en 2014 avec les élections
municipales sur l'ensemble du
département des yvelines benoît hamon la
termine comme sur le plan national 5e
6,93 % des suffrages exprimés un score 4
fois plus faible que celui de françois
hollande en 2012 benoît hamon termine
deuxième pire encore donc dans son fief
électoral attrape avec 24% des voix
derrière jean-luc mélenchon 30 2% alors
à qui la faute les avis sont partagés au
sein du ps dans le département avec une
ligne qui préfèrent défendre benoît
hamon victimes notamment de la mauvaise
image du ps ces cinq dernières années et
coûter malgré un programme qui était
intéressant malgré la personnalité de
nous a montré que quand on demande aux
gens ils vous disent bah finalement son
pouvoir était cohérent et intéressant
lui-même tiens quelqu'un de bien mais
c'étaient d'autres enjeux sur cette
élection
et on voit qui est à la fois un rejet de
politique qui a été menée et en même
temps très clairement un vote utile qui
a fonctionné à plein et qui a siphonné
l'électorat traditionnel on va dire
électorale sur lesquelles on pouvait se
s'appuyer habituellement l'a peut-être
été mal compris ou en tout cas c'est pas
ces enjeux qui ont été les plus mis en
avant dans cette dans cette élection
la faute aux affaires notamment
puisqu'on a un monde politique qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas sain de manière
générale et c'est particulièrement
sortie pendant pendant cette élection et
c'est dommageable pour le débat
démocratique qui aurait dû avoir lieu
a contrario certains estiment que benoît
hamon n'a pas su incarner le
rassemblement au sein de son parti en
cherchant à rallier vers lui tout
d'abord les militants de la france
insoumise c'est le cas notamment de la
sénatrice socialiste catherine tasca
benoît hamon maintenant s'étonne de ne
pas avoir eu le support qui lui était dû
en tant que candidat du parti socialiste
mais ça n'est pas étonnant puisque il a
embarqué la campagne sur une ligne qui
n'a jamais était la ligne majoritaire
des socialistes donc effectivement il
s'est retrouvé à ses seuls dans dans
cette campagne
mon par ailleurs il n'a donné aucun
signe de rassemblement ni au sein du ps
ni en direction des partenaires
possibles et la prochaine étape qui sera
compliqué ce sont ces élections
législatives de juin le ps ne compte que
deux députés dans les yvelines dont la
11e circonscription détenue par
justement un certain benoît hamon
stéphane chanson c'est la disparition
des socialistes du parti socialiste
c'est la disparition du parti socialiste
version françois mitterrand parti
d'epinay 1971 puisque le le score qu'il
obtient est à peu près à peu de choses
près équivalent à celui de gaston
defferre avait obtenu en 69
précisant sa relation du ps et une
redistribution des cartes à une affaire
l'argent 510
oui mais le ps peut se reconstruire mais
il va falloir être clair sur pour savoir
sur quel base et peut-être abandonné le
système des courants qui avait fait
jusqu'à l'heure son succès vous avez
essayé de mettre tout le monde d'accord
en mettant sous le tapis les sujets qui
fâchent est là c'est clair
qu'aujourd'hui il va falloir faire
effectivement le tri sur les différentes
mouvances le parti socialiste on
l'évoquent s'effondre c'est aussi parce
que la france insoumise réalise de très
bons scores dans les yvelines
jean luc mélenchon totalise 36 36 pour
36,6 pour son bureau il attend vous
allez voir les 22,20 % à plaisir les 35
4% à la verrière ou encore les 32 on
l'évoquait tout à l'heure 32,6 pour cent
à trappes écouter luc miserait il est
élu d'opposition à trappes justement
candidat pour le pcf aux législatives
sur la 11e circonscription
c'est le fruit d'une très belle campagne
il aurait fallu qu'on rassemble encore
plus bien on
on a quand même l'espoir que derrière
bien sûr il ya le deuxième tour mais il
ya aussi les élections législatives et
là on a besoin de deux députés qui met
en place une politique vraiment orienté
vers la population et non pas vers les
financiers ce qui est le cas aussi bien
de mâcon que de marine le pen donc
marine le pen
bien sûr pour nous c'est inacceptable
donc on aura le réflexe républicain
en tout cas moi je l'aurais après chacun
fera ce qu'il voudra édition spéciale
sur ted terry film nous revenons sur
cette élection présidentielle on évoque
aussi les élections législatives parce
qu'il ya tout de même une question est
ce que la france un saut mise
aujourd'hui peut espérer obtenir le même
résultat que jean luc mélenchon avec ses
différents candidats
probablement pas parce que il ya ici
pour la france insoumise un effet très
personnelles via la figure de mélenchon
qui pendant cette campagne
en effet est excellent enfin c'est
facile à dire après mais on l'a dit
cependant aussi 577 candidats autres que
mélenchon même qui se réclament de lui
ça peut être pas la même efficacité
vraiment orthez mais il ya peut-être
pour la france insoumise une carte
importante et intéressante à jouer ça
s'explique aussi peut-être que jean luc
mélenchon pour l'instant préfère garder
le silence depuis depuis hier soir
avant de parler des plus petites
formations de leurs résultats dans le
département écouter thibault marshall
c'est l'un des membres des insoumis sur
saint quentin en yvelines jean luc
mélenchon n'a pas donné de consigne
parce que ça ne devrait pas être une
surprise ça devrait pas être anormal que
l'on demandé aux militants de se
prononcer avant de prendre une décision
autre chose on voit que ceux qui se
félicitent de cette élection eh bien
c'est madame merkel et les marchés
financiers évidemment ceux qui habitent
à proximité d'une dune qui avança ou de
la montée des eaux à cause du
dérèglement climatique
e elles sont bien plus endettés par
cette situation
ainsi que tous les précaires évidemment
ceux qui vendent leur force de travail
et qui vont connaître des lois elle
comrie plus plus avec ce qui va nous
arriver par la suite pour être complet à
présent nous revenons sur les réactions
des autres formations qui totalisent
moins de 5 % au niveau national avec
vous nicolas landry alors justement
parmi tous ces petits candidat c'est
nicolas dupont aignan qui est arrivé en
tête dans le département avec 4 34% des
voix un résultat un résultat largement
supérieur à ses 1,73 % obtenus lors des
élections présidentielles de 2012 dans
le département cette hausse pourrait
notamment s'expliquer par le basculement
de certains électeurs des républicains
vers le parti debout la france je vous
propose d'écouter la présidente
d'honneur de la fédération yves
guinoiseau notre première réaction a été
extrêmement positive parce que ben les
chiffres ont montré une 9e une énorme
progression dlf et en plus c'est à peu
près homogène dans tout le dans tout le
territoire n'y a pas deux bastions
particulier dont il ya une vraie poussée
de fond la plus large audience de
nicolas dupont aignan a fait que les
gens l'ont mieux entendu long mieux
compris et aussi se sont rendus compte
qu'il y avait d'autres votes qui était
peut-être moins intéressants et qu'il
fallait peut-être être aller au fond des
choses il ya un autre candidat qui
portait un discours eurosceptiques c'est
françois asselineau l'indépendance de la
france c'était la thématique de campagne
de françois asselineau le candidat de
l'union populaire républicaine obtient
près d'un pour cent des voix dans les
yvelines un résultat meilleur qu'au
niveau national comme on peut le voir
sur cette image avec 0,92 pour cent il
ya certaines communes où on a même fait
deux ans et demi 3 % au haut niveau par
rapport au niveau national on est très
légèrement au dessus donc n'y a pas lieu
de se glorifier de d'un résultat qui est
très faible par rapport aux espérances
que beaucoup nourri sec
la position comme celle du mouvement
c'est que monsieur macron c'est la
catastrophe et que madame le pen c'est
la catastrophe
en tout cas si vous évoquez les ce qu'on
appelle les consignes de vote
bon c'est quelque chose auquel on croit
absolument pas de toute façon on n'est
pas propriétaire des voix de nos
électeurs autres candidats qui
participait pour la première fois à
l'élection présidentielle c'est jean
lassalle au niveau national il gagne
environ
1% des suffrages durant sa campagne le
béarnais a défendu la ruralité et les
territoires un disque ou qu un discours
qui a recueilli les voix de 0 71 % de
l'électorat yvelinois sur les le score 2
[Musique]
% est un très bon score dans une région
qui est assez peu proches en terme
d'idées de celle de jean lassalle
représente 6,6 et ça à peu près à nissan
et des lecteurs c'est beaucoup c'est
l'équivalent d'une ville comme but
donc ça prouve que là aussi le message
de trouver un ancrage candidats présents
en 2012 philippe poutou le représentant
du nouveau parti anticapitaliste avaient
totalisé 0 81% il est sensiblement dans
la même fourchette avec 0 72 % cette
année écouter son représentant dans le
département pour les yvelines on paraît
qu'on ferait un score très bon et
comment la fiev de la droite donc n'est
pas vraiment déçu on appellera pas
l'attention
on les devine ont un peu on lutte
ouvrière et nathalie arthaud son score
dans les yvelines
c'est la stabilité pour lutte ouvrière
dans les yvelines nathalie arthaud a
réalisé un score légèrement en dessous
des 0 4% comme en 2012
une satisfaction pour les militants ils
vont poursuivre le combat pour faire
entendre le camp des travailleurs
notamment durant les élections
législatives prochaines étapes pour
encore une fois nous nous nous montrer
de faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs ont continué cette campagne
qu'on a
comment ces deux depuis quelques mois et
pouvoir toujours aller vers ces
travailleurs pour leur expliquer
justement que cette société
il va falloir la changer que pour la
changer ça sera pas au travers du vote
ça sera pas au travers du futur
président de la future présidente qui de
toute façon un mènerons une politique
contre les travailleurs pour finir le
représentant de solidarité et progrès
jacques cheminade recueille 0 18 % au
niveau national même score dans les
yvelines candidat en 2012 il perd près
de 700 voix dans le département une
déception pour son représentant
yvelinois j'aurais attendu quand même
plus de résultats étant donné qu'il ya
pas mal de gens qui nous ont dit qu'ils
s'intéressaient ses idées donc le
problème c'est que beaucoup de gens ont
voté pour ceux qui gagnent donc par
exemple beaucoup de gens disaient qu'ils
allaient voter mélenchon alors qu'il
préférait jacques cheminade
donc je pense qu'il faut que à l'avenir
ces gens-là agissent avec nous quoi
plutôt que de à chaque fois se laisser
avoir
et pour les législatives on veut avoir
le plus possible de candidats se
dépendra des moyens financiers qu'on
aura parce qu'on n'a pas un financement
public aux législatives contrairement
aux présidentielles si nicolas pour ces
précisions concernant les plus petits
candidats c'est ainsi qu'ils ont été
appelés pendant cette campagne un
signalement stéphane dans ce monde avec
plaisir commenté ces différents
résultats notamment dans le département
des yvelines tous les résultats sur
notre site internet ainsi et que
l'intégralité des réactions des
représentants des candidats replay aussi
sur notre application mobile les
programmes se poursuivent sur téléphiles
[Musique]